dnc they're even finding more ways to
completely embarrass themselves and this
will be on the ballot too and 126 days
claiming in a now-deleted tweet that the
president is quote glorifying white
supremacy by going to the iconic
landmark to celebrate our nation's
independence okay
joining us now for reaction South Dakota
Governor Christie Nome governor I don't
really know what to say now I guess
comrade de Blasio they might be in favor
of sandblasting Mount Rushmore
I guess other Democrats might do that I
have actually been there my kids have
played tennis tournaments in your state
and I think it was one of the most
spectacular things I've ever seen in my
life a work of art incredible magnitude
about people that were not perfect but
created documents that allow America to
right wrongs correct in justices and
also become a more perfect union which
history has proven the right we get
better when we try Sean you said that
you are looking for a new home and I
would think of no better place than the
state of South Dakota where we still
love freedom and liberties and where we
celebrate America's independence and we
recognize the importance of this
National Monument we are going to be
having an event where we will talk about
the principles and the values that this
country was founded on we will talk
about our history the lessons that it
will teach us and I'm hoping that
everybody will recognize that now is a
time not to divide our country but to
unify unify and to heal and talk about
what really is important so we can make
wise decisions in the future governor
meet I would honestly love to live in
South Dakota I love you anywhere near
fantastic
it is a I've been there it is a
beautiful state with great great
Americans they work hard they're
independent they pay their taxes they
obey the laws and we don't see the
madness that we see in New York and New
Jersey and that idiot governor in
Michigan and in Pennsylvania
did you send : 19 patients in the
nursing home
during the height of coal but I don't
think you did we did not in fact you
know Shawn we've got the lowest
hospitalization rate than we've had in
months we're doing a great job in South
Dakota and that's because I asked the
folks here to practice personal
responsibility to make the best
decisions for themselves for their
families and their businesses and they
overwhelmingly did that I told them I
trusted them and they made wise
decisions and we're doing very very well
you talked about South Dakota and our
business environment we are the lowest
taxed state in the nation
we're the lowest regulated state in the
nation we have people every day calling
us asking how can I move there how can I
move my business to South Dakota because
I think the last several months have
shown the importance of having leaders
and people in a state that recognize the
founding fathers vision for this country
and the importance of the Constitution
and how that gives us the chance to
stand on those founding values every
single day to run our lives and I got to
give you a lot of credit governor and
and you never shut down your state and
when you had a hot spot within the meat
packing industry by the way also
happened in two other states including
Iowa you jumped all over it and you were
able to literally mitigate it very
quickly and save lives you deserve a lot
of credit for that because we can learn
in other states how to do it as it pops
up I wish I could be there the third of
July I tried to move things around
tonight actually want to see it
unfortunately I couldn't but I will be
in South Dakota hopefully this summer
and look forward to seeing the great
people in your wonderful state thank you
for your kind words